[Music]
it's the movie sceetos the nostalgia
critic characters you probably didn't
think twice about now in this exciting
prequel we answer the question we know
you've been dying to find out how did
the movie sceetos George it's great to
meet you both
well I guess early backstory is finally
revealed
okay so glad we address what was buzzing
around in people's minds Kino based
tight hugs for that small amount of
children who are developed enough yet -
no we're not funny hi kids
we'll keep you busy while your parents
get that much needed time alone just
don't go on their bedroom for 15 to 20
minutes now Oh
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to and a
special hello to all the movie sceetos
who most likely just reveal their
backstory by God we've been waiting
years years to find that out and now we
can all rest easy knowing that riveting
tale which of course brings us to my
review which I'm sure no way connects to
any of this Flintstones Viva rock Vegas
[Music]
yep after the critical crucifixion of
the first film resulting in not nearly
the profit the studio was hoping to
produce Universal Studios eventually
said yeah those sets were expensive we
got to use them for something those we
have this prequel we didn't know we
wanted with all new annoyances that we
know we didn't want the film seems so
disinterested in existing the knife and
facing the viewer all the way on the
poster in fact the movie cares so little
of what impact it has on you that
doesn't even care what it's rated yeah
the box says PG but when you open it up
the disk reads ji-woo who is the PG
version the uncensored cut the one where
Fred finally does barn it's all as
pleasant as passing a prehistoric indie
stone and we're gonna find out why so
let's take a page right out of misery
this is Viva rock Vegas the intro again
has the pun title universe shale because
lord knows I wouldn't want my wheel
company name attached this either so up
the website gives the real name you're
ruining the illusion Viva rock Vegas and
we cut to the night terrors Marvin the
Martian has when he falls to sleep on
ecstasy did anybody else see those big
letters flying by PG this was definitely
rated PG Christ why do Ellen come in
kids films always paint his face green
and based him in horrific horror
you ought to document the Earthlings
bizarre mating ritual oh hey I was just
kidding don't let the plot actually be
Fred and Barney doing it speaking of
which we cut to Fred and Barney
portrayed by mark Eddie and Stephen
Baldwin in no joke the role I think he
was born to play couldn't even crack his
knuckles without my help
trouble just cold Barney Rubble it's
actually kind of eerie how well he gives
Barney's cluelessness and lack of
development skills okay he has essence
of shaggy stillness but hey that's also
a hanna-barbera character and beam you
be still too if you were on this movie
you'd have to be to allow this to be
your first big joke yeah Flintstones was
always known for its flatulent humor put
up the beds and let's get some sleep I
know that beds in camp we used oh yeah
well that's going on friend is trying to
pass an exam to finally work with a real
dinosaur but it doesn't exactly go great
despite killing a man you still pass
with flying colors hey we don't have any
animal cruelty laws why should this
bother us we've been cut to the family
of Wilma play by Kristin Johnson okay
now this is particularly interesting
because while the casting in the first
film was pretty spot-on a lot of people
had an issue with Rosie O'Donnell as
Betty the shoe is awful but whenever you
look at her you don't see Betty you just
see Rosie O'Donnell even though Wilma
was cast fine here
Betty is cast fine but you don't see
Wilma you just see Chris and Johnson
she's a fine comedic actress but tell me
if you see Wilma or Sally trying to
blend in by auditioning for Earth's
favorite pastime of making shitty movies
I was thinking about going someplace a
little different going into bedrock and
going bowling high commander I made the
Chuckie Cheese animatronics laugh but
this impression of Alice from
Honeymooners eludes me meanwhile Barney
and Fred continued to think about their
futures I guess I always figured by this
point in my life I'd have somebody
special well you always got me Fred
okay I am trying very hard to resist the
gay old time joke but you are making it
very difficult I mean it's not like
something's just gonna drop out of the
sky land right in front of you and
change your whole life
oh my god that thing I just said
wouldn't happen just happened
damn it couldn't be the meteor to
destroy all prehistoric life what are
you
I am your death I come from a planet too
far for you to fathom and a civilization
too advanced for you to comprehend
guitar effects are still pretty shitty
what am I fellow shops here pretty lame
we let you out of the fancy bottle now
we get wishes right yeah Barney's right
let's get this started what do we have
to rub now I have no choice I am of a
highly evolved alien species you look
more like a creation of a TV show rating
slump
hey I'm a born-again Christian
I'm gonna go Creek gullets club later
Wilma meets Betty played by Jane for
koski at a restaurant a glass of water
water free great I'll have to perfect
just one question
what's glass Stone Age
Betty mistakes will not for being cave
less despite the fact that she's
actually running away from her
incredibly rich mother because she hates
her lifestyle you stay with me till
you're back on your feet I know you're
not looking for a handout you're just
looking for your self-respect
after that Schmitt woman inviting a
complete stranger in seems perfectly
normal
sorry I will never get used to how
freaky that is I am here to observe your
species mating rituals so get to it Oh
Barney and me don't okay it's my job
playlist just gonna be nothing but this
cuz who follows them to a fast-food
joint where Wilma gives her first
serving job but Fred seems to miss her
and instead is the hots for Betty
sorry no substitutions sorry I don't
speak Bill O'Reilly you want a date
Bill Cosby just got me a drink why not
you can take me to the carnival tomorrow
sorry I don't be Clinton either okay
bottom line anyone named Bill is most
likely an adulterer some exceptions well
now we know Fred's kill face we'll just
add that to the list of everyone else's
kill face I think Barney is up to five
of course Barney then gets a date with
Wilma which obviously is not a bad idea
and could be a little funny but then you
remember this was directed by the same
asshole who directed these and that
foolish optimism is put out like t-rex
urine on a fire I can surprisingly
suspend disbelief through most of this
but a video camera no I'm sorry we see
pictures are chiseled so we're just
supposed to expect there's a bird
chiseling a hundred pictures per minute
it's like having a live audience in
animation there's another one they add
to the kill face count I'm just assuming
most of the cancer guys show up on CSI
bedrock
they of course end up switching and
start getting along better with the
others dates
oh this paper mache is so heavy
maybe you're right in an animal's rib
cage will make me feel better
Flintstones is kind of disturbing what
do you think about it wish I brought
something to drape over my shoulders you
know thank you
[Music]
okay I'm gonna justify him in this movie
by saying he's the big giant head
checking in on Sally's mission he
already did it once as the home
[Music]
well I swear that never happens yeah
that's right the prize they won at the
carnival was Dino you know aliens
dinosaurs and cavemen all exists at the
same time why should this bother me it
doesn't next shitty scene Wilma's mom
drops by played by Joan Collins Oh as
she interrupts her primordial black face
to ask mama to come home I'm going to
take my bath now yeah it's a cave it's
gonna be dirt
it's a cave she invites her back to
celebrating her father's birthday while
Fred thinks about proposing to Wilma
seems a little fast but to be fair this
movie does feel like years of gone by so
fond what do you think Fred you
shouldn't it's not for you nitwit it's
for Wilma Oh
probably for the best I'm saving myself
for Pauly Shore they meet at her
mother's house to discover she's so rich
she can hire John showers of LA Harold
and Sulu parka card he don't tend to
make that by the way Wilma's dad is
played by Harvey Korman as you can
plainly see he never recovered after the
Star Wars Holiday Special
you're using coconut Fred is intimidated
about his ring when he sees the family
she comes from and it doesn't help that
Dino interrupts the party also
well this is a fine how-do-you-do surely
the chef's desserts will make everything
better but Wilma sticks up for her party
ruin her that is why I like them because
they're not like you how dare you talk
to me like that Wilma no one has ever
talked to me like that before
they usually dress a club club your fish
beloved love but chip rockefeller huh
chip Rock no you were right not to laugh
advance feels bad about how the family
acted and invites them to his casino at
rock Vegas I don't think now is such a
good rock Vegas
no god no god dammit as if we didn't
have enough chill faces in this movie
now we have to have the one from Judge
doom at the end of Roger Rabbit rating
this was a PG when PG actually meant
something
[Applause]
[Music]
you
so everybody is of course off to rock
Vegas so yeah wonder what prehistoric
law and prostitution is here hey hey he
said it not me he's a hard drinker and a
hard smoker isn't this kind of like the
next logical step so even though this
movie is bad I will give it credit that
it doesn't really have a predictable
plot
it's just Fred and Barney meeting Wilma
and Betty and going to Vegas honestly
I'm not entirely seeing where this plot
can go and Wilma will see him for the
pathetic primitive primate he really is
ah there's our you see chip
wants to marry Wilma so he can inherit
her fortune to pay off some gangsters
and do I even need to say it you've
heard a million times but hey it does
allow for the crossover we've all been
waiting for the Flintstones meets the
Leprechaun and the Jolly Green Brad
Garrett speaking of threatening a little
green nightmares let's think
he explains Rockefellers plan but it
leaves little to no impression on our
dumb as a rock hero good luck dumb-dumb
you'll need it I think that's what every
ticket taker said when going in to see
this movie look dum-dum you're gonna
need it good luck dum-dum you're gonna
need it
good luck dum-dum you're gonna need it
meanwhile Wilma and Betty get a massage
from an unlikely cameo did you get
between my shoulder blades that's where
I carry all my tension ha she's tense I
just found out what calamari means
finally a fitting role for Rosie
O'Donnell in the Flintstones Matson's
casting her as a chimp as a spell so
right Barney as well seems to be
enjoying himself
look at the size that PUD won't you I'm
totally clueless to where this is going
I'm gonna say they all kicked eight
syphilis and died or the pine goes in
her face one of the two let me help
oh now we're doing this stupid thing
Christ the storytelling connects so much
to our everyday lives
how many cream pie misunderstandings
will it take before we learn no it's
okay
I was just wiping my white hot cream off
her breasts and I laugh
this leads to Ellen coming in a double
role because if I was in a Flintstone
movie I would want double the attention
play rock star Mick jagged what do you
say we go meet me bein nice then maybe
guys somewhere more clients so we can
you know how bad is it that Flintstone
kids is a better prequel than all of
this Fred it looks like is getting way
too into his winnings and chip decides
to sabotage him by pushing a lever that
forces him to lose no literally he just
pushes one lever and Fred magically
loses all his money to the casino people
to lose everything
marry into money why you have God's
personal money tree that's not even any
complicated controls it's just when and
lose is it only targeted a friend can't
be targeted to other people is there a
remote control chip in everybody's mind
that he somehow has control over and I
can win or loser
this whole movie should be about how
that lever works but nope we don't focus
anymore on that because he instead tries
to woo Wilma by saying he'll put her
priceless pearls in his safe which for a
casino seems surprisingly small and an
open view for everyone to see but it's
okay because they rip off the dumbest
subplot of Titanic yep they slipped
Wilma's pearls into Fred's pocket this
is horseshit you said in 1997 Leonardo
DiCaprio you said even when chip seals
off the casino asking the wrongdoer to
come forward and confess I don't think
there's anything that could possibly
make any of this remotely funny
ethically poisoning the dinosaurs water
supply in a matter of decades their
entire species will be extinct
Doyle you actually had a funny line god
I think that's like the one funny line
and the entire goddamn movie doesn't
anybody care about this whole dinosaurs
becoming extinct thing no no please
can't we follow that another guy's story
why did he do it how did he do it can he
save a couple so we can reenact I know
writers that's that's good
he of course reveals Fred as the culprit
and even works in Barney as an
accomplice and Wilma being as dumb as
everyone else in this movie believes it
this means Chiefs plan is working and
just in the nick of time see a little
birdie told him that you ain't even
datin this leg that bird was going a
little too Dumbo for my taste but if the
bride don't show you'll be spending your
wedding night with me what happens in
rock Vegas stays in rock Vegas damage
and his name is rock Vegas meanwhile
Fred and Barney sulk in a jail cell we'd
be with them right now if I hadn't been
so stupid now I told you that so you're
gonna bust us out of here do I look like
the cavalry those outfits are adorable
no I can't actually interfere if you do
I'll make sure you never do another Spy
Kids but Barney finds a way to sneak
through the bars and get out through the
bars okay meanwhile both Betty and Wilma
think they were happier with the people
they're still under the impression we're
cheaters and thieves I'm leaking I don't
know somehow Fred and Barney dress and
drag do you really care how they
eventually break in and try to get Betty
out of mix hands I just had to come back
here and tell you I love you I don't
think I ever told you that before
but now I did so goodbye you will
believe Stephen Baldwin as Barney Rubble
as a showgirl will win an Oscar mostly
because you were dropped as a child hard
and repeatedly do you really mean it
of course I do I've never felt this way
about anyone before
Oh Barney after all these years I
thought you were after my fruity pebbles
no I was all the trouble to pinch a
nerve from him in the first place you
will forget I can do Shakespeare as chip
tries to force Wilma to marry him Fred
sneaks onto the stage dressed like how
babies are made this isn't love this is
ecstasy Oh Fred you sing horribly
whoaaa I never forgive myself I didn't
give this one last try wilma slaghoople
will you walk off the set with me Wilma
William will you MA yeah she still
thinks he's stole from her he's clearly
got a gambling problem but he's so in
love with her he can't even say the word
married when proposing Christ I wish we
were watching that guy who was gonna
wipe out the dinosaurs who oh there he
is
tell me your motivation what's your plan
that me or all the dinosaurs died
because of people like you that we're
getting seventh race for my movies she
of course says yes and they're married
in a church which raises so many
religious questions about this world
since the Flintstones Christmas do you
fred flintstone take wilma slaghoople to
be your wife uh yeah but dabba doo i'm
saying that line under protest
good night everybody no refunds
and that was Viva rock Vegas I think
it's very obvious that came up with the
title first and wrote a movie around it
it's not even a very good pun loss rock
they don't sound alike much like the
first one it's got some good impressions
and one or two needs set pieces but it's
just pointless unfunny and creepy when
it's not unpleasant it's boring and
there's literally no reason to have this
be a prequel just take out the four the
meeting for the first time and keep
everything else the same it's still just
Flintstones being Flintstones its
catchphrases bad puns and awkward scene
after awkward scene this film is just
one big yabba dabba dump not Nostalgia
Critic I remember it so you don't have
to let's see totally unnecessary let
make somewhat of a profit which means
there'll be many many more movies sceeto
adventures like ghosts buggsters hot
buds infection the mask
steena that of parasite bugs means and
Hamlet and don't worry parents will make
them really crabby so we can get them to
you faster enter all you adults who
would actually enjoy watching these
things go sleep my son please be kind of
yourself well that's about it from the
movie sceetos see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
oh there's a lot of Bush gonna be sold
hey everybody Doug Walker here doing the
charity shout out doing a real cool one
this week we are doing Team Rubicon Team
Rubicon unites the skills and
experiences of military veterans with
first responders to rapidly deploy
emergency response teams their primary
mission is providing disaster relief to
those affected by natural disasters be
they domestic or international by
pairing the skills and experiences of
military veterans with first responders
medical professionals and technology
solutions they aim to provide the
greatest service and impact possible
they seek to provide their veterans with
three things they lose after leaving the
military a purpose gains of disaster
relief community they'll by serving with
others and self-worth from recognizing
the impact one individual can make
coupled with leadership development and
other opportunities Team Rubicon looks
to help veterans transition from
military to civilian life as well if you
look at their site and their YouTube
page you can not only see what an
awesome idea this is but also how
incredibly helpful it is to so many
lives check it out and see how you too
can help
you
[Music]